I was gonna show a game that I just
analyzed today for I just looked at it
today for this article it has my comment
I'm I just so but I know the game very
well because I spent most of this
morning working on this and I thought
I'd I'd show I think it's kind of
instructive this was a game really old
game from a basically the first World
Championship of chess its will hum
Steinitz versus johannes ook retort so
you heard of these players Steinitz
zuker tor was his first official World
Championship opponent in 1886 they
played to match this was the first one
that was officially for World
Championship and Morphy had died and I
think 1881 so this was and back then
things moved more slowly but they they
could have a actual World Championship
without everyone thinking ok this guy's
the worst says there's a world champion
but still there's Morphy and he may be
kind of crazy in something and doesn't
play chess anymore but they didn't want
to have a World Championship out of
respect to him who would speed everybody
you know even me maybe even then while
he was but once he died then they could
have a World Championship right so this
was this was I don't know it basically
I'm doing column about end games and
this this is an interesting in game I
think was kind of instructive maybe not
the most exciting game but so steinitz
was he was white and E 4 E 5 ok Knight
f3 knight c6
and Spanish which was back then you know
I think a lot of the games the match for
Spanish like this and Zook record shows
the Berlin defense
so that's Knight f6 right away 114 years
later who who chose the Berlin defence
for a very important World Championship
yeah
hmm okay Magnus Crossan also but that
wasn't 114 years later that was 128
years later yeah yeah kramnik I mean
that was how he became world champion
that's how he finally ended Kasparov's
reign was and it's not because he won
any games in the Berlin it was just but
he held off Gaspard every time at the
4way because probably never got anywhere
and then Kramnik beat him a few times
with with white when he was white you
know so Berlin and the idea is that
black has taken upon on e4 and then the
night is in retreating to d6 in most
cases so okay castles if white takes
time out to guard the pawn and I think I
mean this is one move you can play of
course and played about half the time
probably here but it's not as critical
as castles because you don't want to
spend a time making d3 move you can do
it of course to keep these keep the game
from out of this type of stuff that ends
up happening okay so castles and Zook
retort took on e4 basically I mean this
was a long time ago and we're gonna see
that steinitz approach to this wasn't
even close to anything that could bother
someone but okay so now you take c4 this
idea and does anyone know how white
usually the most common way of playing
yeah
d4 yeah and the idea is if black takes
then you have this you know pin here and
that's not good for black so 90 to d6 is
the move normally okay and then this
bishops under attack
so then it usually goes takes takes
takes to the pawn and then we trip then
they trade the Queen's and this gets the
famous endgame we're Kramnik held off
Gaspar and what's going on here is white
has this majority of four pawns to three
on the Kings side and white has
disturbed the black King which even
though there are no Queens on the board
can come in under trouble and come into
trouble has happened lots of times that
the black king is come under attack
there's still a lot of peace in the
board on the other hand black has this
LightSquared bishop so he has two
bishops but it's it's it's really
particularly important here because
White's pawn on e5 has gone a little bit
far forward so this Bishop has you know
can do a lot of stuff and then White's
Queen side pawns often end up on the
light squares as well so it's it's you
know a lot of lot of battles in this in
this endgame but this was a you know a
long time ago and okay sine it's played
this move and and this is also a move
okay Knight to d6 and now he took on e5
okay black obviously can't take the
bishop because then you know you lose
the Queen right so so so he just goes
here and now here Stein it's played a
move which is just really not this will
take c6 it's not something anyone would
worry about anymore because people are
not worried about these doubled pawns
basically here they say you should take
toward the center right but B takes c6
here would be would be a bad move why do
you think what's the problem why would
nobody play this here
why shouldn't you play this yeah yeah I
mean a pawn is weak first of all and it
blocks this Bishop and the problem is
black may have more pawns in the center
but he can't use those pawns very well
because let's suppose okay in the future
yeah he's gonna move his knight out of
the way maybe to f5 but when he pushes
this pawn the C pawns are gonna be
backwards so it's not gonna be that easy
for him to use those use his extra pawn
in the center that he would have
compared to the game the game meanwhile
now he has the open D file and he can
put pressure on the open D file and
that's pretty important and he's freed
up as bishop and his pawns are very
solid there's not really a serious
weakness here but we will see that there
is a certain kind of weakness in Blacks
Queen side if things happen in a certain
way so okay took Queen e2 so the idea is
obviously if black castles the black
castles
what do you think is going to happen
yeah yeah we're gonna attack this Bishop
right and then takes Queen takes right
and then you got to watch out in some
positions there could be this move with
this rook hanging but here Queen takes
and this work is pinned so there's no
there's no taking on you know there's no
tactical bloomerang which you got to
watch out for though you can't always
get away with that because there could
be a situation where then it it rebounds
on you and you get checkmate on the back
rank or you lose your queen but okay so
that's that's pretty obvious nobody's
falling for that at the world
championship level so Bishop e6 is
what's Zuka torque played and now d3 so
Steines play is real simple and actually
that's just putting the bishop on f4
which is what he did it was not really
threatening in this game but it did get
me thinking because I saw that there are
some real actual insert in other
positions are some real threats to c7
again if black castles now what do you
think White's doing here
yeah taking f7 right because even though
that's guarded many many times and I
can't even count
what about four or five or something
it's still this bishop is under attack
on e6 and and this one here is also you
know so maybe maybe Black has something
after this and then here I don't know
but it's probably probably not coke
sorry
probably not quite enough play here I
don't know I mean maybe he can hold a
draw somehow it's not easy though so you
don't want so black doesn't want that so
night of five okay it's easy to deal
with that threat night of five now
bishops guarded on e7 so no problems now
okay night to d2 steinitz played castles
c3 guarding d4 and I was thinking like
first of all I when I first saw this
game I saw that black just kind of got
outplayed at first that was my first
glance just flipping through it and I
was wondering well I mean I know this
position is totally totally
unthreatening for black I mean I don't
think the black should be a slightest
bit worried here
I was looking at different things and c5
was one thing that came to mind trying
to keep this pawn back but the way he
played was fine but you know and then
okay maybe white can build up some play
like that Bishop a4 with d1 I don't know
so it's blacks Queen could end up having
a little bit of that's one of blacks
small problems as the Queen needs to
find a good spot and then will
eventually try to play d4 if the Knights
back on f3 a particularly but okay he
could play that way but the way he
played was fine he went rook e8 94 so
letting the bishop out and then I was
thinking also f6 just to chase the
knight back so it has to go to f3 and
view of what happened and then maybe
this move and again I don't think black
has a slightest problem queen is gonna
come up maybe to d5 or d7 rook the da
Bishop f7 and blacks those bishops just
lurk back there you know one thing is
one things getting better at chess
involves having a good judgement about
minor pieces like bishops versus Knights
that
everything which situations they're good
for how what their value is and like
here I guess someone just starting off
from chess they're not going to feel the
the power of blacks Bishop's lurking on
f8 and f7 but to trust me I mean they're
doing something back there for you for
instance keeping the whole Queen site
under fire okay so it's okay so it's so
he played this which is also fine Bishop
before the wreck a to d8 again he could
play f6 and chase the night back okay d4
and black black has this one weakness on
c7 that he has to be a little bit
careful about so we went here and now
Knight c5 and in the bishop went back so
really black is fine here I think
totally fine because he's got his rooks
coordinated in the center on their ideal
files the Queen has come out it's it's
it's not in any real danger
the Queen is you know not because
generally that was one of the problems
black had to deal with the bishop is
safe and the other bishop can come to f8
if it needs to c7 is not reachable so
it's so let's see what's you know what
happened now Bishop c8 Knights white 193
f6 Knight here okay attacking the Queen
black went here so the Queen's are
traded and they took back and then white
went here and now this is an important
moment so what do you think black should
do because this was the most instructive
moment I think in the game because first
I would say here well I mean my opinion
blacks should be better especially after
he plays the right a couple of moves
which he didn't do and then it ended up
that steinitz got the advantage maybe
small again if it's some advantage so
yeah
Bishop d6 okay I think I play this but
for one thing I can do this
this is now hanging and I'm gonna take
this pawn and also a sevens hanging so
tactically it doesn't but even even like
in principle you don't really want to
exchange your bishops when you're yeah I
mean I'm probably blacks fine here but
okay I mean in principle you don't want
to exchange one of your vicious when you
have two bishops because now you don't
have to bishops anymore right thing is
bishops compared to Knights they move to
more squares they have a longer reach so
they're stronger pieces in one regard
but in the other regard they can only
see half the board they can only see
thirty two squares so that's why if you
have two bishops well now you got the
advantages of the bishops without the
disadvantage but if you only have one
okay it's it's equal to a knight
basically here are maybe it's a little
bit better than a knight but on the
other hand blacks positions a little
constricted I don't know maybe if some
moves like this but but okay in any case
it fails tactically I guess two eight
takes be five right so I mean it looks
you know maybe there's some chance but I
don't see I think they look right to me
so what else
yeah and then also there's this issue of
this pin here so there's moves like
Knight c5 well I mean a for the Knights
gonna be able to go to d6 so it's not
like why has a winning threat this is
more of a question about positional
stuff
a5 so a5 okay white has to go night - C
- right yeah and now just show up f5
yeah I mean it looks great for black I
don't see any sense I don't see the
slightest hint of a problem in his
position I see that only black has the
initiative here okay white maybe it
doesn't stand too much worse but Black
has two bishops no real weakness and now
we could do put some cramp on like this
maybe a little bit or do some other
stuff
I don't know can advanced pawns and I
king king f7 looks like a useful move a
lot of a lot of different stuff and
we're not worried about losing that pawn
because the night before he tries to
chase the night it can come here and
then maybe to see for this Bishop is a
strong piece you know so but the main
thing is he he did not he played Bishop
f5 right away which it looks like not
much of a difference right now even
threatens 85 friends to win a piece
right I mean a5 we'll just knocked a
night away from b4 and then take tit but
he totally underestimated a real
thematic ideas that white is pushing
this Avon up to a 5 in this gaining the
space here this is real important and
we're gonna see that well I would say
black stands considerably I mean not
maybe not totally not considerably
better but you know comfortably a little
bit better here versus what ended up
happening in the game where white is
totally out of any danger
the only person playing for a win and
maybe not a huge amount better but he's
you know he's a little better and cause
black to make a mistake and we'll see so
he what he didn't what he underestimated
was the value of white pushing the pawn
up to a 5 which is creating a permanent
threat to Black's Queen side weakening
b7 fixing b7 as a weakness the possible
of a six creating the c5 square for the
night as a base by making b6 difficult
to you know so what he did was he went
Bishop of five and now a four okay so
Stein it's understood and another thing
is rook pawns are the best way in a lot
of cases to gain space have you ever
seen positioning it's not clear what to
do next you go h5h for and you gain some
space and cramp your opponent's position
or you weaken their kings side a little
bit they're great pawns to advance for a
gaining space because they only most
pawns you advance a pawn it weakens two
squares it leaves behind two squares at
least on either side of the pond right
if I pushed up for I weakened e4 and g4
then you know but if I push this point
if only we can be for I am i weakening
this pawn over the square over here cuz
it doesn't exist
so that's rook pawns are advancing Rick
pawns are a good way to gain space I
mean every position is different but so
here where there's not a whole lot of
immediate plans just this little gain of
space becomes real relevant so a for now
what should black do it's a little bit
more mmm so there's a couple
possibilities and even what he did
wasn't too bad but he could have
guaranteed a draw first of all which he
probably should have considered doing
its tactical idea here his time
couple tactical ideas and I mean
Whitey's pieces look very shaky right
so you don't want to let the pawn just
get to 85 a knight moves to d6 pawn to
e5 that's what happened and black was a
little worse than OC so what could black
do instead I mean there's not too many
other candidates right yeah you could
play a five here I mean probably this is
not the type of move they would consider
in the 19th century but you know I mean
this looks like it leads to a draw
because of White Knight moves this hangs
on d3 so you got to take the knight
right black takes here now this is under
attack so you have to take here black
takes and now wiped and throw in the
taking on e8 so the d4 won't be hanging
but it's it's gonna be a draw regardless
and then black will take here and then
you know I mean this is just White's up
a pawn but this pawn on b2 is gonna fall
this is not going anywhere
so it should be a draw and this I mean
Kim cut you can advance to d6 but black
is easily holding that off and you know
realistically White's chances of winning
are not not very high so that's that's
one thing black to do another thing is
another tactical idea is all these
pieces Bishop here guarded by the night
but the night is under attack and this
Knight is guarding that night this night
is under attack so so then I mean this
move becomes pretty pretty obvious right
I don't know if Sukkot or was a great
tactician he might have seen it but he
just decided not to do it because takes
rook takes yeah I mean this is under
attack right kind of not really but it's
pinned yeah I mean but this Knight is
under attack
it's overworked but white has this move
I guess this was only
yeah then black can do this and he's
down the exchange but does two pawns for
it and two bishops are strong and blacks
not in real danger of losing here this
is also this works under attacks there's
no time to take this you're gonna move
the rook somewhere and then black will
play a5 and or c5 and maybe you and you
can blacks better I don't know he's got
those strong pawns supported by bishops
I would rather take black I mean that's
apparently it's more or less equal that
I mean actually I would rather have the
black pieces if you think about it it's
not easy to use the rooks at all because
the bishops cover all the entry points
and meanwhile they support potential
slow advance of the passed pawns I mean
the main thing is I don't see a plan for
a white but for black there's lots of
things you can do bring the King to
Center solidify the Queen side start
pushing the C pawn c4 Bishop d3 you know
start slowly advancing those pawns it's
tough for white a little bit so that was
something really worth considering I
mean I was totally forcing right Knight
takes d4 have to take it I mean Y has
some other move but I don't know what
here using the pin but I guess black and
just do something like guard the bishop
and prepare to take this nevertheless
and still await the same problem because
if that Knight moves the one on d3 hangs
something like that probably looks like
but okay so that's this is a little bit
irrelevant to our thing he he just
played a normal move 96 okay and now
what should we do 85 yeah I mean white
so so this is the thing is like in this
position I didn't you may you may be
looking at this position at first he's
white here and you're thinking you know
it's vague what you should do rook to d1
okay black threatens e5 you see the
tactics but understanding that this this
just pushing the a pawn and the huge
value of getting this up here now if
black stops the pawn it's
95 and the situation has changed a lot
because this Pont is now really fixed
this pawn on f5 is holding back these
two here you know I mean pawn is fix
this pawn is stuck the knight on c5 is
now almost can't be chased away hardly
you know I mean like Knight moves in
this pawn on b7 Falls and this pawn by
moving up there is beat has become quite
threatening for black you know as the
game goes on that's what happened but
black didn't play a6 and I think he made
the right choice I mean because this
this position looks seriously difficult
for black mm-hmm and she's very passive
so I don't know it looks looks tough I
mean if he if he gives up the pawn on b7
somehow you take care but I mean then
everything else is a weak over there and
he gets this pawn but I mean all these
are weak and then when this Falls this
a5 fun that's no good you can't do that
so he he went night here oops
he went night here so he allowed
Steinitz to push a six and I don't know
maybe even should maybe even sign it
shouldn't have even taken the
opportunity there's possible moves like
I don't know this to bring the King up
to f2 but sure black might one thing he
can do is sometimes trade these get
office of colored bishops and hold a
draw somehow that way but okay so so
Stein has decided to play a six and
really black has only one answer to this
I mean his queen size being destroyed if
he pushes here Knight takes right and
then if black takes here what do you
think white does here
and it is I mean it's a tactical
situation blocks up a piece so we got to
decide we could take the bishop with
check but okay I mean King comes here
and knights under attack blacks down a
palm but maybe the pawn on a six will
fall somehow but there's better yeah
what do you think take the rook yeah
because even though it's attacked twice
both of those captures you know this
loses the rook and this loses the bishop
so white wins a whole rook that way and
is up the exchange that's so that's best
so he can't play b6 and of course if he
allows white to take on b7 his whole
Queen side is destroyed so his only move
is to take on d3 to deflect White's
Knight so and then b6 and he can't allow
his Queen side to be broken up by taking
on a6 for instance that's just too awful
all those pawns will be weak so here now
basically we've seen the situation has
changed enormously before you agree that
black was probably better if he played
85 and Bishop f5 I mean he had the
pressure white had nothing at all I had
no real pressure on black black had
those two bishops he had no weaknesses
he had lots of ways to improve now first
of all black had to give up his main
advantage the two bishops and second of
all this pawn on e6 is a standing threat
for the rest of the game and you can't
really you can't you can't really
overestimate the danger by his pawn on
the sixth ring because for the rest of
this game until you start a new game of
chess this pawn is sitting there two
squares away from cleaning and it may
have this pawn in front of it but as the
game goes on all kinds of things can
happen and that they can cause this pawn
to be under attack or can be removed or
that type of thing you know so this
that's just you know practical terms
that positionally this is a huge
achievement for white but if black I
think plays well here he can he has
reasonable chances to hold so Stein it's
when rookie three wants to double the
rooks and he found it was natural but I
don't know if that was really the best
way to try to press this position I
don't know
gasps Carlsen how to play here best
because he's really good at those type
of things
maybe rookie six better way to threaten
c6 yeah
like still does this I suppose
maybe you can trade things in the night
before will happen it's no blacks you
know okay that's regards it passively I
suppose because if this comes here then
we mean maybe black can do that too so I
don't know or instead of doubling the
rooks because it could have just led to
the trade of all the rooks he could
place a move like I'm always wanting to
play this and then king f2 to get the
King into the game but okay why he
doesn't have a whole lot and there's
such moves like c5 and that type of
thing with counter play but okay rook e3
so black played a normal move king of
seven rook e1 and here black just played
total just the worst move you can see
practically I mean it's a funny thing
you know I mean these were pretty good
players you've seen that they've they've
played reasonably well I mean this was a
long time ago and you tend to think that
they're just terrible players nowadays
compared to now but you know you did
there wasn't a huge you know it's not a
terrible it wasn't terrible play but now
suddenly zoo Couture just played an
awful move I don't know I think it's
because first of all his health wasn't
that great and he got tired there was
everyone said this and also maybe he got
bored in some cases and and also back
then if you look at the games like
there's there's big groups of people
standing around the board smoking cigars
and stuff you know that so it's a little
bit different situation it wasn't less
of a sport and more people you know
they've spent a lot of time playing
these moves and they're just discovering
all this stuff back then the opening
from the very opening there's thinking
and there's a lot of more philosophy
than nowadays you know that the players
are playing 10 15 moves automatically
and they kind of know all the patterns
much better and then there's a lot more
time to spend on on small details but
hero kaizuka toward played this totally
ridiculous move I mean who would put
this bishop into a pin so he's guarding
c7 but I mean this Bishop is never gonna
be all move he just loses the game
okay so what do I do now stupid thing
over here says oh yeah says training
that the whole idea is to hide whatever
is written there okay
night to be for I mean this this Bishop
is the bishop is pinned so he that's the
worst thing black could do not only did
he pin his own Bishop but he allowed
White's night to get active real active
so can't take that night because white
will just take on a yeh so blacks only
move is is well okay if he plays c5
White's taking and the bishop can't take
because rook takes the eight
if pawn takes knight c6 and this is
awful for black because all this pieces
have to guard this so he can't even get
out of the pin this King us to guarded
you can't move as canvas rook away
because it's required to guard it and
the night also has to guard a seven and
white flight takes that pawn this guy's
gonna Queen and that's the work that's
that like White Queen a pawn is about
the best result black could have here
anyway that's not playable so he zoo
Couture was very clever though and he
came up with a way to play on he went g5
ok bishops under attack retreats okay
whatever now he went f5 again c5 so the
idea is the okay friends up for easy
defense f4 and blacks weak in this
position but now he can go c5 because if
white takes obviously what is black too
yeah yeah it takes to the bishop and
here F for exposed the diagonal so okay
I mean he's definitely clever zookas
word but I mean Rick t7 I know okay so
so but still so why can't take on c5 and
make black take back with a pawn like
before but he still goes into c6
black takes on d4 take back okay that's
not what I wanted but it's still good
enough right now black is just
completely tied up ninety five is
threatened so he doesn't have a time to
take here because then this fork is
coming right so he has to play King f8
and now here
Stein has played a move which was good
enough to win in principle I wouldn't
even consider taking there because he's
just not going anywhere right you know
so yeah so what else could we do here
ruk t5 is what he played so that's a
good move that was good enough to win
whether you have to see a fair fair
amount here okay there's an even better
move though because we don't I mean that
one was enough to win okay there was it
was it was good and white should win
after that maybe it was a little bit
harder to if I could defend it better
maybe Whitewood they ended up having to
play longer but it should be it should
be a win after okie fight but there's
okay let's look at this from the point
of view of black he desperately wants to
liberate this bishop but neither what
can move the King can't really move at
all and basically because of this and it
has to guard that in any case King f7
doesn't do anything it's only one idea
is to take care just to try to take this
pawn and get rid of whites Knight that
way so can white stop him from doing
that
yeah
well what would happen if you push the
pawn it creates a little problem here
right so yeah Bishop c5 so no he can't
push the pawn it's a hard move to find
basic basically I mean Bishop f2 this it
looks strange I mean but Bishop f2 a
black can't take on d4 now because now
the bishop seemed it the rook so you
have what do you play here take on e7
right yeah and then you know take here
check rook e1 okay so that's so you
can't take the pawn this kills the only
plan black house the only idea that you
can even possibly do and if he takes
this here then maybe rookie six but
basically now or Riki five I don't know
but anyway now Bishop h4 becomes an idea
and plus black simply has no moves I
mean he can he can be in zoogs long in a
moment the knight can't move because
it's gonna hang a7 is already gonna then
this pawn will promote soon I mean it's
basically so it's terrible and if he
doesn't take on f4 his plan has been
stopped and white and he could go here
trying to come in to you for but yeah
now I suppose you can take the a pawn
right no I don't want the knight coming
in to you for maybe it's not right here
no no you just play rook e5 okay just
preventing any counter play that's the
idea I mean here in this position
keeping him tied up ninety-four okay now
we take that's the point so now there's
no ninety four and again black can't
move his pieces he could go Knight to c8
but I mean this is getting pretty ugly
right he still can't move any pieces
Plus this is also we can his rook can't
even you know even if he gets the Knight
to c8 he still can unpin because that's
covered by the knight so it's kind of
sad position so I feel like what signage
did didn't quite justify the position
but it was still enough to win
so you went a rocky 5 ok black takes d4
it's the only chance obviously 96 wait
just takes on g5 it's ugly and though
the same as before even worse so now
white takes ready because blacks
threatening the night and now it takes
here takes there and still blacks in
this ugly pin he's got a little bit of
activity compared to before and he's got
rid of that terrible night on c6 but
this pin is still his problem
so really steinege had to have seen
though if he if he was he had to see in
the next move so you could swear played
which could have turned that turned the
table somewhat Bishop here I mean
because what you don't take on ei right
you see what happens after rook takes c8
what happens now
checkmate right rook to d1 double
checkmate so so I mean black doesn't
have to play Bishop c5 you could play
something like work to d2 but really I
mean why can't win the bishop yet but
it's it's ultimately bikes to the Flex
pinned and it's just you know maybe take
here I know you have to watch out for
this check right so white has to be a
little careful but okay maybe maybe move
the King here or something and it's uh
yeah but I can't take me to because
Bishop e5 mg6 and then drop back to f6
after after all said and done right I
mean takes check takes takes and then
this
should be enough to win just the a7 pawn
will fall at the end of everything take
take take bouquet eight rookie seven see
how this is important don't even we
don't know what the adventures are gonna
happen in the next 20 30 moves we know
that a6 pawn is there so I know there's
probably other ways to and I'm just
looking at that off the top of my head
but anyway okay so he played Bishop c5
well so what does white do now here he
does he goes he's still I mean if he
needed to probably probably needed to
see this from the beginning if he did I
don't know whatever and then the
following what happens
right is I mean what's the move you
wanna make there's a piece that's really
Al's blouse black to take the bishop and
then make it discovered and discovered
check
yeah Bishop e5 I think you can just go
King g6 yeah I don't see any way to use
the discover attack but King g6 now what
is way too too many things hanging right
rook f6 check I guess you can do this
it's looking scary
maybe White's gonna lose so I know what
else good way I mean what's the move you
want to make yeah yeah rip 65 you gotta
make that we'll try to make it work and
this is a forcing move and you want to
play this move I mean maybe there's King
f1 but then box pieces are real active
maybe you can even go and take the a6
pawn who knows I mean it's anyone's
guess what's going on there maybe
White's better still but you want to try
to make this work because it's removes
blacks whole basis of his position now
the rook is hanging on e8 so black has
to insert this check if he takes back of
course white just takes on e8 so he has
to he has to insert this check okay
white takes back you know hmm
yeah pin the rook right bishop c3 so now
the question is the King and pawn ending
he has to also evaluate this from this
position Italy I mean miniplayer it
takes e5 probably didn't you know he
should have when he played rookie five I
kind of doubted I don't know who knows
probably maybe he did but you don't need
to calculate everything when the King
and pawn any okay goes here you trade
you just have to see that you play h4
and he can't do anything to the Kings
side pawns because you're gonna have g3
it brings the King to g4 you have g3 and
you won't be able to take on g3 because
h5 that's the main thing and then
meanwhile black has this past pawn it
be a connected pass pawn but the crucial
thing is why can undermine it by b4 so
whites plan is okay black can't leave
the Kings side you can't stray too far
because white will Queen then why will
bring the king to d3 and then undermine
the pawn with b4 get rid of the defender
take d4 then takes d4 and then come up
and take a 7 and we know that these
pawns are tying black up on the Kings
side and they can't be attacked because
g3 will keep them completely so really a
little bit of logical thinking you don't
have to calculate the variations but
some logical thinking you say okay this
winning you know that's that's the thing
yeah you need to be absolutely sure with
before you go into King and pawn endings
because at this point you know the die
is cast you can't go back and they're
gonna find the right moves generally but
you know because they're so so concrete
but here you don't you don't have to
look at every single move you just have
to realize okay you can't do anything
you know and then you know that so black
black played King f5 okay
King f2 he went
kingi for if he goes King g4 we're not
worried we go g3 and now we're gonna
bring the King to d3 next okay so he
went King e4 okay tries to keep the
white goes there he tries to keep the
White King over there now he went to c5
if he went d3 okay whatever
white can always divert you know it with
h h5 and then why it's gonna divert
black and there's a still pond on g2 so
even black takes the pawn on g6 you know
why it will divert this is one way to
win oops
and then you know black is gonna do this
and okay but there's still this pawn
there so then white goes and then
suddenly oh yeah a six pawn so even in
the King and pawn ending okay probably
it's winning even if the pawns in a two
but still it could even in King and pawn
innings that could have been relevant
depending on how they
when it's okay so black went to c5 now
what should white do here this is very
important I think without this move
White's not gonna win then huh
yeah b3 you got to play b3 because if
you allow c4 it's suddenly not so not so
no probably white wins anyway because
even if you louse even as let's say the
pawn is on c4 but the King on D - you'll
play h5 you - no nevermind you can't
play b3 because c3 and blacks you know
so yeah I mean you have to play b3 so so
black plays King e5 again d3 it's the
same diverts the King and then King
comes up takes e5 and push the pawn to
b6 and clean the a pawn
so King e5 King g3 looking at for if he
played that I mean what else is there
King d5 trying to keep the the two pawns
you know that but then h5 eventually
black is gonna have to go back okay you
can go here and then G for you then so
we can it can be more tricky I'm
probably g6 wins - but I mean we can
keep the King from there and then if you
goes here we got our what should we do
here yeah yeah we got our undermining
move we break up the pawn chain so
attack the base of the pawn chains even
relevant in this position of course if
he goes this way so before we don't want
to do because c4 well here we go g6 King
is too far away now what do we do here
yeah just queen the phone or maybe we
don't need to take on g6 although that's
winning - so he played King a game round
up with he played King f4 and now would
we play
hmm what does white play now yeah um g3
check is fine of course yeah you just
play b4 in black resign g3 is fine of
course two in either one yeah I mean
yeah before and black resigned because
it obviously has to take your c4 which
one we take do you for don't take care
because then suddenly now I guess you
lose right no it's probably still a draw
but okay both Queen anyway but we take
d4 obviously so if it like takes here
then just take here
go and take b4 and then take a seven
while blacks busy well you can't even
take any a White's King cyclone so
obviously well time to resign